welcome to this video playing duwayne du
quoin I'm someone explain to me how to
pronounce that but i forgot it already
so we have fun okay let's set up an
English opening probably I can play you
for then we have a Sicilian by
transposition
yep if you had cheto variation g3
something yeah like black should be in
pretty decent shape here
probably am this is around equal so
okay he wants to play it with c4 try to
activate the bishop here
mmm i want that be 16 this a 5 is so on
the one hand that looks like
positionally good idea but after taking
Queen takes b3 as a weakness
hmm yeah 95 this well-known trick so
should I put step out of it yeah maybe
keep it simple not spend too much on
he's playing it anyway great yeah um
yeah sure why not the real problem is 97
that this is this is threatened okay but
let's let's let's grab your grab it so
maybe not so terrible
and this is this is an issue taking 1e6
but I can I can take him and no no II
five or should I take it hmm
you five ropes is six but i got to know
I don't have not be eight hmm and if I
take yeah this is simpler I need to take
just for the tempo and then take a five
intending 95 and III I could have played
95 immediately hmm this would have been
interesting attending 93 okay okay this
is just the simple and go to strategy I
hope you can always okay you can take
and play D sixth and sister his idea I
see okay so attack the pawn I'd get the
look out of the diagonal night c5 you
would have taken play d6 and no I don't
know this is simpler
yeah let's see I'm going to win the be
born and I wasn't even so slow for a
change 95 I could have played rook a
six-night c4 funny fork hmm maybe I
should have done that but took him but
it's probably not bad him the bee pollen
seems to be gone maybe rookie three
maybe yeah if i take it now
but ok probably something like this is
the most annoying move there's also now
quit to you one as a possible way to
distract white and a 585 to a form
hmm
yeah maybe Queen a Jew or something it's
um it's not very comfortable to play the
position a five yep no I'm no I can can
just take it
mmm rook if Bishop f1 this is a problem
should I go all the way back
oh no nonsense Bishop everyone I can
just take the five
oh this is an interesting
trying to get something on g7
like to exchange queens of course maybe
just go back here and then tend to clean
be one okay Queen 84 and then then the
Queen going to be two or something like
when a one queen bee two are now queen
bee to protecting the g7 square
k attacking d6 mmm
93 to e5 maybe
or take on f2 not sure what's better
this fox the two of the two rooks but
the question is do I want to take this
hmm yeah it's not so clear what the heck
you're sure I want to take it Bishop g5
and dentin things time morning
white4 face on time yeah probably i'm
busted here yeah yeah okay calm possess
is equal whatever but i certainly
spoiled spot on my match in the problem
is that here I should take f2 I should
just take F to this is this is this is
not a real fork because if i take on c6
he takes with the pawn and this is an
excellent position for white excellent
compensation I only saw the fork but I
didn't really calculate further mmhmm
yeah the computer points are looks like
an f5 here winning instantly with
supposed to see that I don't even know
understand it and so check it briefly
what does f5 not about if it takes
there's rook f8 and f2 okay app yeah
hard to see and the rook okay is only
one square then it says a three and then
promoting yeah okay but I'm not a
computer this is fine I what I need to
take f2 now this pattern just just
grabbing their and continuing with 95
not grabbing the exchange or something
just centralizing the piece this is good
yeah this is in fact very instructive
here this isn't even good for me I
computer gives white and clear edge
already of course at this point I could
have one on time bye-bye any move almost
but I wanted to play good once I don't
don't know I should have taken f2
problem this is the way to go okay
thanks for watching